I woke up this morning feeling pretty
good about myself then I got to CES
where I discovered all the new
electronic products that want to make me
look better first it was sculpt this
thing told me and I could use a little
bit more time at the gym because
apparently my muscles they're covered in
fat inside the 100-dollar device are
twelve sensors that measure the
electrical current flowing through your
muscles spray some water on the muscle
you want to measure place the device on
it and it will report the percentage of
muscle versus fat yeah it looks like I
need some work don't worry I found
something else that can help me fit into
my pants quite literally this is the
belt II and it's about that vibrates to
help you move more the belt II gently
vibrates when it thinks you can stand to
pick up the pace and be more active it
can also be customized in an app
apparently my skin also needs electronic
health this is the janu and it uses
ultrasonic pulses to help better absorb
skin progress you rub in your regular
cream apply some conducting gel to the
device and then gently rub it into your
skin
Janu says this hydrates your skin and
forces the moisturizers to sink in after
this show I'm probably gonna need one of
these too this is the hair max and it
uses lasers to stimulate hair growth
seriously my head is getting pretty warm
right now the laser bands eighty two
beams stimulate hair follicles in 90
second treatments the company says the
$700 FDA cleared device reverses the
thinning process and increases fullness
not a wig real hair